[Música]
a primeira coisa que eu acho que tem que
dizer pra vocês sim eu sou o cristiano
está engajado no projeto aí que
supostamente é muito legal estar desse
estágio shell finné e e esse projeto é a
gente faz um monte de coisa lá mas a
gente trabalha com basicamente esse
negócio de inovação tecnologia e
empreendedorismo startups nec está muito
quente e muito conversado por aí tá
então esse negócio do estado depois de
escutar vocês eu acho que eu tenho há o
dever de dizer que o que nos engajou no
início desse projeto a empresa super
jovens em algo muito diferente é não
convencional é que a gente acredita que
o brasil tá calado assim não só os
problemas internos que a gente tem uma
história tudo que está acontecendo no
mundo lá fora o que vai ser da gente por
isso que a gente quer essa crença que só
inovação e empreendedorismo são um capaz
de salvar o brasil
a nossa operação funciona em são paulo
mas a gente tem um escritório lá no rio
em são francisco tá então são francisco
aquino mapa ela em cima tá é aqui
embaixo da cidade são você daqui aqui
são mais ou menos 100 quilômetros
isso aqui é o tal do vale do silício
certo e muita gente hoje pergunta do
boca a história vale do silício é que
essas empresas tão bacana surgem lá e
daí tem uma frase em que sempre responde
que é olha na verdade isso não tem como
criar uma empresa bacana tem criar um
grande time e se tiver criar uma empresa
bacana é certa essa é brincadeira lado
vale é eu gosto muito desse desse tema
do paypal máfia não se ouvia falar isso
essa turma criou essa startup da paypal
os caras que saíram eles construir
empresas incríveis pessoal que saiu de
lá e criou o youtube teve um pessoal que
sair de lá e criou a omertá esses não
conheço a microsoft comprou por 1 bilhão
de dólares à empresa o yelp
o scareware o cara investiu no facebook
linkedin mas eu vim hoje por
recomendação do do falado da arrancada
dele que ele adora que é o islão mas que
a gente tem uma piada que quando as
coisas vão bem as coisas vão mal dias
bilac long an seja que nem o cara tá bom
então lá quem é o vilão
willam mas nasceu na áfrica do sul pai
dele era engenheiro e piloto a mãe era
uma modelo canadense
ele teve um irmão e uma irmã aos quatro
anos ele já lia tudo
devorava livros aos 10 anos ele teve o
primeiro contato com o computador esse
aqui é o o o commodore para quem é novo
parece um teclado né sim não tinha
monitor no dia a não não não tinha de
ver nati que ligar na tv pra gente
enxergar as coisas
aos 12 anos ele aprendeu ele mesmo a
programar e ele fez o primeiro jogo de
computador chamado blaster e ele vendeu
por 500 doses certo inclusive quem
quiser curioso entra na internet até
jogar joguinhos muito simples
em 1983 ele tinha 12 anos ama nem tudo
era fácil na vida do do irã ele sofreu
muito de bullying que uma vez ele bater
um livre na escola e desmaiou
ele aos oito anos a família os pais
separaram e teve que morar só com o pai
né ea vida dele lá em na áfrica do sul
também não era fácil na época do
apartheid
é aquela coisa da a a segregação racial
não é um lugar muito bacana vamos dizer
assim
e ao mesmo tempo essa cultura da áfrica
do sul também não favorecia muito o
empreendedorismo à aquela coisa que
tinha muito nato dele então em aos 17
anos ele foi morar no canadá com a mãe
logo depois ele foi estudar nos estados
unidos ele se graduou na verdade em
física em físicas em economia
lá nas universidades americanas de bom
eu acho que bem inferno em dizer que ele
é meio nerd meio geek certo então ele
tem uma frase que diz assim quando eu
era bem pequenininho eu realmente tinha
medo do escuro mas depois comecei a
entender o que era escuridão e talvez o
mister peter pode explicar pra nós os
fundamentos científicos das críticas
depois eles depois que eu entendi não
tive mais medo desse negócio era bank
daí ele aplicou país tam for fazer o
bilhete dele lá em stanford ele atendeu
à aula por dois dias por causa do fogo
por filmes em alta
então o medo dele tinha de perder aquela
balela bolha da internet
então ele se ele queria empreender ele
foi prender ele pegou o irmão dele o pai
dele prestou 28 mil doses para eles
criarem sua empresinha chamadas voip 2
exibiu e quatro anos depois eles
venderam a compacto por 307 milhões de
dólares
ali ele fez 22 milhões de doses são 28
anos que é feito 22 milhões de doses o
que ele fez foi com a disney mentira ele
três meses depois ele começou outra
empresa 99 chamado ex boston é com 10
milhões que ele tinha e daí ele fez um
médico outra empresa
loge eles criaram uma empresa paypal
certo que fazia pagamento eletrônico
na época o grande dificuldade deles era
conseguir cliente deve teve uma sacada
assim se tudo indica um cliente e ela
vier eu te dou 20 pratas para gastar
disse ao indicar outro do 20
se ela gostava do 20 ele gastou 15 6
milhões de idosos fazendo isso ele parou
de gastar mas as pessoas não param de
entrar sério isso hoje é chamado ground
ranking bem bacana
foi ele que começou a criar essas coisas
malucas mas ele era muito maluca não
ele era muito maluca nas coisas dele e
meio brigam lá dentro da empresa
tecnologia e resolveu tirar umas férias
ele foi o australiano quando chegou lá
os caras ligar pra ele sem ilan
nós estamos permitindo desse ou não dá
mais certo foi por isso que ele disse
esse é o problema de tirar férias por
isso eu nunca mais tirou férias da vida
dele tá bom mas tudo bem porque no outro
ano a ebay comprou a paypal por um
bilhão e meio de nós
nesse caso mister manske william fez 165
milhões
tá e aí ele pode desenvolver na coisa
que era mais curtição dele que na marcha
ele disse assim eu nasci na terra mas
vou morar
vou morrer em marte não na chegada certo
essa é a frase dele e aí ele foi na
rússia e tentou comprar foguete dos
russos russos eram sim não vou temer um
foguete e oito milhões de doses não é
muito caro
vou fazer os meus ele pegou 100 milhões
de doses e comprou mim e começou a
empresa nada chamado spacex certo e ele
gostou tanto diz que descobriu que uma
startup lá tentando fazer carro elétrico
ele falou dos 70 milhões de dólares
nessa startup chamado teste lá e aí ele
estava embalado né
daí ele foi lá e achou que os primos
dele criou outra chance source em que é
painel solar energia solar
o cara tá bombando daí chegou 2008 puxa
pra você ter uma idéia do que aconteceu
isso aqui você conhece aquele programa
60 minutes tv americana aqui mais ou
menos o cara tá perguntando assim as
irmãs que esse papo e explorar o martim
o espaço os astronautas o governo tanto
dizendo que você é louco que você está
falando é insano
você vai machucar as pessoas que tu acha
disso vocês podem olhar as lágrimas ali
no roteiro certo e eles realmente esses
caras são meus heróis
e eu queria que eles viessem ver o
trabalho duro a gente está tendo aqui
na verdade tanto até doha como spacex
como a solar cid estava acabando a
grande e ele não estava conseguindo
investidor por aqui mas deus sabe o que
aconteceu
a mulher dele largou ele certo e neste
momento ali e daí como ele já era um
cara público às informações do mercado
de que aparecer e daí não é só as
empresas que estavam ruim era ele que
não tinha mais grana pra fazer um
negócio e por isso que ele disse 2008
foi o pior ano da minha vida e aí
aconteceu uma coisa quando no natal no
natal mesmo tá na piada no natal ele
recebeu uma ligação da daimler mercedes
dizendo nós não botar 50 milhões de
dólares no negócio
a tesla ok eu não sei se você tiver
oportunidade de ver tesla então vamos
dar uma voltinha então estão dando uma
voltinha de 10 lac agora ok estamos
andando pela pela pelo vale do silício
aqui está lá por acaso nosso motorista
não está mexendo nada então vendo porque
o tesla além do elétrico é autônomo e
tem oito câmeras nos modelos em oito
câmeras e essas câmeras estão vendo a
direita as câmeras também levou também
dá um quadrinho corrida ele está
identificando uma árvore um pedestre e
um cachorro é uma placa de pare uma
placa dourada esquerda uma placa pra de
velocidade certa se chama computer
virgem
tá lá tem um programador ali programando
essa placa para lá essa placa
não não é bem assim na verdade quanto
mais informação imagem nós jogamos mais
essa chamada inteligência artificial
mas esse negócio processo então quanto
mais ver mais usa melhor o bichão fica e
se chama chillán em de planning e é meio
assustador porque a gente não sabe bem
como é que o negócio aprende e quanto
mais usa melhor fica todo dia de noite
download de software na garagem e vão
embora ea coisa está cada vez mais
é incrível aí pra vocês que talvez não
conheça a tese mas conheço a gm ea ford
então aqui diz o seguinte em 2016
há até mesmo a perder 1 bilhão a gm teve
um lucro de 9 a ford 4
daí a até da faturou só 4 bi
a gm for mais de 100 até da fez 76 mil
carros a gm quase 10 milhões
êêê abrir em 2017 até as lá começou a
valer mais do que a gm o que é isso é
uma aposta de quem vai ganhar esse jogo
talvez certo vamos voltar pro vão voltar
pro spacex qual era lógica econômica
dele o que é caro se eu pegar um foguete
jogar lá não quer largar o satélite e eu
pudesse voltar esse foguete inteiro e
não encher de combustível abastecer no
posto e mandar de novo e econômico em
matemática louca mas fica muito há muito
mais barato fazer isso certo só que
então agora é como se eu convocasse você
o seguinte agora todo mundo está
trabalhando no space é que está certo e
nós vamos tentar fazer isso tem que
levar um foguete falar trazer um foguete
inteiro pra gente poder usar de novo só
tem um problema a gente já tentou fazer
isso várias vezes
cada vez que a gente errou e dispor de
um foguete nós perdíamos uns 40 50
milhões de dólares e o dinheiro acabando
ea última tentativa que a gente tem
tá bom então eu vou convocar vocês por
três minutos você são trabalhadores da
spacex ok eu quero que vocês olhem o
masc e olhem a cara das pessoas que
trabalham com vocês quero ver se é santo
paulo de frontin
mas quer saber
[Aplausos]
em candeias
o nome dele não é fácil chegar
ivan ramos por sakineh ainda assim o
jovem a ter 6 em troca por um ônibus
santo ainda sente um pequeno essa
crescente e deixa o plano
[Aplausos]
sim sabe certamente foi
foi assistente de cima e que deve ser
usado pra isso se repetiu hoje que
quebra o resultado
o conceito
[Aplausos]
danielzinho
eu não sabia nem se ela responde dúvidas
existissem ou então é a mostra uma foto
vocês
isso aqui o que será marte segundo o
senhor mas que tá bom a a colônia em
marte é essa eles têm esses super mega
foguetes que tem o nome feio e aí o que
acontece e eles dizem que em 2022 vão
mandar dois foguetões só com suprimentos
para marte em 2024 eles vão mandar
quatro foguetes 2 com 12 com suprimentos
e dois com passageiros 100 pessoas em
cada um então o senhor mans que está
indo bem solarcity não só a painéis
solares agora tem uns telhadinhos
solares né
também tem as baterias power ou seja de
noite de dia pega só o bota na bateria e
alimenta casa na ideia que energia será
grátis para todo mundo que mundo será
esse
é daí também brincou com o rapper lupe
vezes clicando no botão tudo assim eu
quero edição francisco los angeles e 15
minutos que ele trabalhe são francisco
que mora em los angeles na então que
vida será a gente pudesse daqui para
floripa em 12 km e meio né
daí ele também agora ele quer um
impressionado o pneu planeia e ou seja a
inteligência artificial aberta ou seja
eles desenvolvem tecnologia e deixou
liberado para os outros utilizar que
legal
daí ele também criou essa empresa como
tráfico é muito ruim se eu pudesse
estacionar o elevador leva baixo cria um
cano mj lá do outro lado da cidade ele
criou sua empresa estão fazendo isso
aqui tanto aquele teu nome muito legal
né de bola em campo nem tá pra isso e aí
ele esse ano pra acabar ele inventou uma
outra chamada neura link
o negócio aqui é mais ou menos ele criou
uma interface entre o cérebro humano e o
computador não sei talvez por fazer
download de coisa
esqueceu alguma coisa faz o upload até
lá tá então esse é um ano bacana e
semana passada ele lançou os caminhões
elétricos
ele lançou o novo é carros esportivos
dele até o roadster aqui na verdade um
carro que vai de 0 a 100 em 1.951 da
primeira vez um automóvel faz menos de
dois segundos está aqui o super bugatti
quer mais rápido esse aqui valendo 200
mil doses é que três milhões de dólares
o cara não para né ele diz uma frase
dentro da companhia dele diz assim fale
aqui é uma opção
se as coisas aqui dentro não estão
falhando nós não estamos inovando
ok essa história dele e obrigado aqui
[Aplausos]